hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and oh God I forgot where I was
righty hoe then
did I do it what it is that important ow
don't don't stop don't stop don't do
that different ideas
all right I didn't want to pay for the
coffee
so was that oh I need to hit him more
than once ah I see well this is a
problem
I didn't know that
ah more than rice
[Music]
did I do it oh that flow didn't work
huh well that's not good
oh huh
[Music]
what do I do what do I do
[Music]
well I'm not paying for coffee that's
for damn sure yeah that's right
[Music]
now
well
that didn't go too good
man the hitboxes are a little wonky
foreign
well I guess I'm done then
I've uh I've did it all righty then
well good thing this is charged up
still don't fully understand the
technology behind that but welcome back
to the episode we're going ahead and
we've killed a big
fear shows our true nature why I killed
some big spider thing which is always a
good day
hello where is this
Alice
Alice Alice Alice all right are you
there
Alice Alice where are you
it's dark
I don't know what to do wait there I'm
coming to fight you just don't move
how do you know where I am and also why
didn't you do that before and why didn't
we work together on this oh
careful you'll reveal your true nature
master your fear
whatever
hello
oh it's okay I'll hurt you but I don't
want to hurt you and that's the
difference all right they always run
when I say things like that why do they
always run
why
well good an emergency shaft that's
often his convenient
that's what you get
that's what you get
that's what you get for existing that's
what all of you get for existing
I don't like you guys stop existing
this is extremely worth doing hello
goodbye
hello
I probably missed more [ __ ] didn't I oh
see those things are hard to see and I
need so many of them
all right but down I go oh there we go
oh didn't
mean to move I was told not to go
anywhere and yet here I am going
anywhere why did I go somewhere I was
literally told not to move and here I am
moving I believe there's something
special in all
who are you don't you know me take a
good look
[Music]
In the Flesh
come on up
let's take a little walk
there's something I want to show you I
was supposed to wait for a
Alice I was supposed to wait for Allison
then I didn't do that so I'm feeling
that I uh might have made a mistake here
might have not done the waiting thing
and that would have been a lot better
for me
Mr Drew
Mr true there you go follow me okay
this old place is full of surprises sure
I should know I've worked here a long
time uh-huh Mr Drew Joey please Joey
what is this place
Studio
psycho Audrey
Audrey an ink stained nightmare forever
stuck on repeat well when you put it
like that and With a Little Help From
The Jet Corporation
came into being
from what I gather it exists in parallel
with the outside world completely
removed from the march of time like a
record played over and over again great
it's begun to crumble wear down
this studio is a monument to choosing
the wrong road
now whether it was built for revenge or
regret
I don't know
that's my riddle to solve
okay the truth is Audrey come on out
there there is messing with what's in
here bad things have begun to emerge
from the puddles Wicked creatures that
never came from my pet
the worst ones call themselves Keepers
dangerous deadly folks they've taken
over the old jet Workshop just beyond
the sewers trying to bring what they
call order to this world freezing the
cycle in place changing the script
whatever answers you're looking for
you'll find them there what if I don't
want to find any answers what if I just
want to get out of here what if I don't
really don't care about the whole world
that we're in what if I don't care if it
all gets thrown into Inky hell what if I
just want to get out of here what if I
don't want you what if I hit you with
this pipe
we all have questions Joey Drew
a reason Audrey ah there's always a
reason great even when you can't
understand it thanks
why can't you fix it because I'm not the
man
I'm just the memory
oh it was a ghost
do you think I can do that too just
coughing my way through walls just melt
into the being of everything
um well I definitely didn't wait for
that other person but hey more batteries
that I apparently need or something
and this every Story begins in mystery
although things may be dark at the start
the truth will illuminate your way don't
be afraid of who you are fear only what
you may become and banish it away
I I don't know if that's as reassuring
as you think it is I don't know if
anything of what you said could possibly
be reassuring to me oh no just a pencil
and a dream and a goddamn ghost
[Music]
I'll kill you all right
hope the real uh
was his name bendy didn't see that don't
ever lose hope when in doubt the answer
you seek is usually nearby we all have
dreams ghosts in our past but those
ghosts can give us the path forward
uh-huh you're telling me there's more
ghosts
I'm a ghost I'm a ghost you better run
away
man I really didn't stay put
man Alice was all like don't move and I
like moved so hard
Lord I'm mock rules is that like oh
Doyle
like O'Doyle rules oh so many of those
necessary
I don't have what I need I need so much
more please
a skadoosh
I have a funny feeling this is supposed
to be for much more than just opening
doors why would they give me so many
batteries if it was for just opening
doors it makes no sense I say they call
me crazy I say but I'm not crazy they're
all crazy I'm the same one I'm the one
seeing ghosts of Joey Drew everywhere
and not moving when Alice says stay put
For the Love of All That is Holy don't
move wait this is back I don't want to
go back
huh that's where I met Joey Drew
and this is where Lord amok rules
stay my zoomeda stay dead unsafe area
gent Corporation okay
you got it
I'm ready
why do I hear sprawling you doing these
mirror in some kind of springy doing
these
um
nothing good
hello
who lives here what ghost be here oh a
secret you say
uh there we go okay
huh yeah who lived here
instinct to what you know works but when
they built the new studio buildings they
all been filled in my office down in the
old sewers turns out I've gotten so
accustomed to working in those
disgusting conditions that now my office
lyrics all right do so and Jen started
digging their massive utility shaft
between their place and ours I knew it
would be just the right spot for me to
move in now I've got a song to my heart
and a creative stench of my nose
wow all right that's weird but you know
maybe there's something to that
maybe uh maybe stink is the source of
all creativity or something like that I
don't know I haven't tried it so why not
no no no no
oh
Lord amok
I think I don't even know who Lord amake
is
I don't even know what Lord amok is
um
fascinating
anybody got any kind of idea of what I'm
supposed to be doing here I don't even
know what's going on between all the
ghosts
yo
I don't even know why I'm here
I'm unlocking it
hope I don't have to go back and charge
that up again because I really don't
want to
they designed this big tunnel to link
their new gent building to Joey Drew
Studios they want to keep labor and
parts flowing between them I don't think
they fully knew what they were accurate
actually creating here when workers are
heading through the shaft you gotta
drain the center duct into the overflow
when they're gone you flood it again any
schmuck can do it even if they're not an
engineer but the main thing is you got
to make sure all the duck hatches are
all open once they're open the Overflow
can drain back and forth between the two
ducks simple stuff but a bit complicated
when you're working by yourself
okay
so what does that have to do with them
building some horrible monstrosity down
here who is Lord amok oh yeah sure
throw every random switch that I can who
cares about security slam down all the
Securities what does it matter nobody
cares there's no rules
I'm guessing I'm trying to drain that so
that I can carry on
but who knows I've heard multiple
different hidey holes they're all the
same right
it wouldn't actually be anything in any
of them probably not anyway
uh-huh it's probably fine to do this so
I'm gonna do it
oh it works
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
okay
idiot
he'd never think to check the hidey
holes
all right did that go all the way down
or is it only partially down I don't
know
see if I can drop
I can I'm sure that wading knee deep in
ink is going to be good for my health
hello
okay is that what I needed to do that's
kind of reminiscent of what that message
said but I'm not sure if that was
everything I need to do but I guess I'd
fill it again for some other reason
I'm not exactly seeing the connection
here but
all right
oh I didn't know I could well wait a
minute wait a minute
oh where am I
oh I didn't know I could go in the ink
like that I thought it would just not
let me go in but okay all right well
don't do that
I hate your hair
all of your hairs
that's what you get
sponged Into Darkness
over here wasn't I already over here was
that not over here I don't think I was
there's another security lock over here
this is different an upgrade man I
stumbled into this man this is random
happenstance thank you for that
do you mind if I smash my fist into this
it's the only way
wow good thing those exist for more
power or something I think anyway more
ability
I like my flow but I think I did
whatever I need to do to do the thing
that it tells me to do I think
which is something important that I
definitely need to do and I know to do
still known of those repair kits that's
good
um I guess I need to get up there
all right I did it I think
what did that do
what does that do
what did it do
oh
what did he do
what did that do
did that open the thing do I need to
drain it now maybe if I drain it now
it'll go back and forth between maybe
it'll drain both of them I think
oh you're gonna kill me oh you're gonna
kill me nope no you're not hey hey hey
hey
that's what I thought
good thing you have so much food on you
and I definitely am full of Health now
for friends
okay so long as nothing else
I don't know where to hide out well this
is a problem I'm gonna respawn just as
it gets me that's a bad thing
never mind I tricked it by dying it
never suspected that am I good to go
here yes
yes I am I'm out of here
seeing nerds
see you later
thanks for not actually stopping me
good for you
I'm good with that within our isolated
walls Lord amok Reigns The drips and
drops of the leaking world above cannot
stop his rule those who oppose amok's
hand have their bodies crushed and fed
into the narrow pipes that lead below
into forgotten sewers under our feet
those tunnels are even deeper and darker
than this one there is only suffering
down there but should anyone defeat
lordamak cast him down our small Kingdom
will be long to the Conqueror this is
the secret of amox immortality pass on
the throne pass on the name
uh-huh yeah
okay am I Lord I'm up because I kind of
killed a spider thing so I'm pretty sure
that might be me
possibly
possibly I really don't understand why
the Gen Corporation decided that a
ramshackle pipe was the best key in the
world oh nope okay I thought that was
gonna be real smooth with my flow
leaping me across the Gap like that but
I guess not
but oh well the last I guess it doesn't
matter screw me then everything I want
to do always fails hi die
I wasn't gonna talk to you anyway
thank you
was that a string was this booby trapped
Oh I thought it was boom trapped oh
hi what's up yeah uh-huh
[Music]
okay what if I kill you
aren't you guys stuff take this and this
and this and this and this and this I'm
King now I'm King now I'm Lord amok
I'm Lord amok oh you're tough
don't worry about it don't worry about
it this is fine
mine mine mine
hi hail yep that's me let me just pop a
squad here
yeah that's me baby
thanks for being here you were always
loyal to me I'll never forget the either
of you whatever your names are what
are you away I got very important Lord I
mock business to do
[Music]
so saith Lord amok you heard my decree
pass it on
it's ends
don't listen don't look into it
okay all right hail them up
wow holy crap I'm rich oh my God I'm
rich
The Spoils of a buck
nice oh finally two of those that's
definitely as many as I need it's
definitely not gonna be just not enough
it's definitely not
definitely certainly not
now I'm gonna get that upgrade
oh my God look at all the goodies except
it's not the goodies that I need but
it's okay
it's chill it's cool
was that all that was in there
do I uh
am I done well I don't know where I'm
going
you don't believe in me well
I Am Lord amok apparents
will I
Brazilian but it never ends it's a cycle
I was told that by Mr Joey Drew himself
um also did a I'm looking down
I really didn't wait
I did not stay put
oh
the world how big is this place oh
oh hi oh it's you
where did you come from
look
I'm sorry about earlier
I I didn't mean to hurt you and I really
don't think you want to hurt me either
right
good let's be friends then okay what do
you say you and me
awesome maybe you can help me I'm
looking for the old gent building
what's wrong
is it a bad place
it's okay I won't let anything happen to
you we'll go one step at a time yeah
just you and me you're coming with me to
this horrible bad place new best friend
don't worry about it you won't be in
terrible danger you definitely won't be
in a horrifying trouble
it definitely won't be awful for you in
every way what happened to Alice I
really do feel like the old Alice thing
is completely forgotten
so uh
because we just fell off Frick hi how
you doing
all right let's go wow oh
ah it's a whole city
so you tell me Wilson managed to get uh
all this under his thumb that's pretty
ambitious for him
I mean kind of well done if you think
about it you know he did a lot more than
I certainly have done so far all right
I'm gonna go then I don't think there's
any Collectibles out here anyway so it
looks like we need to find an ID card
somewhere around here any ideas bendy
any ideas
[Music]
oh okay now I need to search for things
okay
so who would have an ID card it's got to
be something suspicious looking here
that I can go get
somewhere
all the haunting music keeps me company
was there something back here that I
missed do I need to go backwards at all
no
there's no way he's not coming back in
so therefore well
oh
good job oh
The Future Has Arrived I just didn't
know it would get here so soon some
other stuff that's coming out of Jen
doesn't follow any of the rules of
physics that I know hard to believe they
started as a bricklaying company Once
Upon a Time nowadays we have all the
modern conveniences and worse yet the
headaches take that ID card machine that
got at the door you don't bring your ID
you ink into work so I started putting
my ID card on my nightstand in my room
at the downside Hotel it's not the
safest place but at least I know where
it is
yeah better than your um
your
pocket
oh
the downside Hotel you say
I'm sure that it's a perfectly wonderful
establishment that's not gonna
what oh
I'll just start my own place uh-huh hey
what did I do to you what did I do to
you what did I do to you
well what I did to you was turn you into
mush forever but also this isn't the
hotel
the beef is people
[Music]
hurry
um how how people is the beef like
what's the percentage is it like an
unpalatable percentage of people
also what is an unpalatable percentage
of people
hey friend you want to be my friend you
want to be my friend
all right I guess you didn't want to be
my hey I need that
eventually once I'm able to get to the
crafting upgrade thing again I don't
even remember what the upgrade was for
I don't even know how it's going to help
me at this point
hello
oh hello
[Music]
size
every time I walked by the workshop
shells are the two small to the floor
that and I gotta bend down for a victory
in the place so there are some positives
to work in here I mean take that new
circuitry the shiny one with the blonde
locks the one who follows her in Mr Gray
I'm pretty sure she's been given me and
my muscles AI
not fine
ah and your muscles you say well
interesting I would believe it 100 I
couldn't understand any of that so if
you couldn't hear it either don't be
alarmed that was it was someone with a
thick accent while music was playing and
it was kind of quiet and hard to hear in
the first place
well this is the first place it's been
kind of creepy
no
there's no way don't be ridiculous
whatever Aubrey
come on
fine
I don't think I could possibly inject
any more sarcasm into my way of speaking
so I'm gonna carry on what am I supposed
to be doing
why did I come up here
am I crazy wait am I crazy oh
hello
please
stay open
and you're done
that's all I needed from you hey someone
at the top Suite here
you have gotten far don't do that
wait
how
did you get in here
oh I have my ways
so tell me how goes the journey
slow
but I'll get through ah I see you have
your fathers never quit go-getter spirit
oh now you knew my father well news
flash I didn't even know my father
for my mother
or anyone else in my family
I see them you've chosen to forget the
past
I can understand that what are you
talking about look
I don't think you're ready for this but
hang on to your lunch money
there's something I want to show you
wait what are you doing
yeah it's a little weird
um
don't know why you thought that that
would be okay to do out of the blue but
um I'm holding on to my lunch money I
suppose
all right Joey and Joey I'm here I'm
here
let's see if we can find what you wanted
me to say yes
okay uh
Oh Come have a seat
this won't take long
so it wasn't Wilson in the first place I
remember what it was I remember that
from this is the first game or at least
it's the start of the first game anyway
I'm gonna take a seat but first i'm
gonna just glance around real quick
don't mind me
oh I can't oh I can go this way dreams
come true
how far can I go
well not that far yes that far
why can't I go this far why is it
letting me go this far oh
my God
oh my God
oh my God
oh my God all right
um
hey I'm back hope you didn't mind me
exploring a little bit uh I'm back now
hey what's up show me the thing play the
tape
I like movies very old place
full of memories
but never mind
there's a little story you need to hear
you ready here we go
Once Upon a Time Audrey
there was a bitter old man when lost
just about everything
Joey right
the real Joe Drew hmm he blamed everyone
but himself for his mistakes but mostly
he blamed his old business partner for
abandoning their work years and years
ago a man by the name of Henry Stein
great artist
friend
in his anger
Joey used an evil machine to create
another world
a world made of paper
torment his own version of Henry
forevermore
but one day a miracle happened
an angel came into job's life a young
woman by the name of Allison Pendle she
didn't visit often
but when she did
she saw something good in Joey no one
else could
including himself
through their friendship he began to see
the world with Better Eyes
so one day in Joey's cartoon cycle of
hatred
he gave Henry an angel of his own
to guide him when things were most dark
to always provide hope it was then Joey
decided to make something new
something he had always wanted but he
could never have
a family
but not a cartoon one
something real
and after many many tries he created
something
ever could have imagined a wonderful
loving daughter
bright kind
Almost Human
[Music]
he created you Audrey what are you crazy
listen I know it's a lot to believe who
do you think you are I wasn't born from
some machine flesh and and blood I'm not
some kind of ink monster just because
we're born of Darkness doesn't mean we
belong to it
we're always free to choose believe what
we want to believe take me back right
now I'm not listening to any more of
your lies remember
[Music]
leave me alone
[Music]
[Applause]
uh-huh okay yeah oh I believe you
no it can't be it can't be it probably
can't be that would be really weird it
would be really weird if it was true
that would be super Omega bizarre if it
was true am I out of gent cards live no
more
second
Wham no gen cards
[Music]
nope
apparently I didn't get any more
Collectibles either I have not been able
to get anything I thought I've been
exploring pretty much everywhere but
apparently not
oh well Hey where's my buddy hey but
no
hey stop
stop
thank you
[Music]
hey what
I thought you wanted to keep the cycle
what break the cycle I thought that's
what you might have wanted then again I
don't really understand your motivations
buddy
Mr Wilson uh Mandy where'd you go
bendy
bendy buddy buddy
bendy
also what happened Alice hi where's
bendy
bendy
whoa because I'm like the president
seems like I'm just abandoning everybody
that has been a part of this
who needs it I'm
not
oh
well that's probably not good
oh
well that's definitely not good
thank you
it can't be
now I'm blown my mind blown in half my
mind blown completely out of my ass
where'd you go
where'd you go
where'd you go
no way oh my God
well aren't you a dick bag and a half
way
we're doing
what are you doing well you think it's
just been too long since I had a scare
screw you
whatever
I don't like to ask questions I believe
everyone's got their own business
you leave it alone
I'm in and out of a jug as I am you
learn to keep your mouth shut about
things you know so when I saw this here
Adam in newspaper that reads gen
Corporation looking for research
subjects pays 350 a week I figured it'd
be good easy money right with my record
you can't afford to be picky
it turns out ingredient wrong is going
on in this place I mean I've seen dead
people before but here death is like a
way of life A Clockwork March
they wheel out of bodies and they
disappear down the shoe forgotten men
from the street
paid to die
3 15 week
350 a week I don't know what era it is
but 350 a week probably in this area is
very good so you know what's a little
death hey I can finally
all right
it's about damn time I love that it
looks like an old cigarette lighter
that's very nice in there Unleash the
Power of the punch use shock pipe to
launch a devastating series of heavy
attacks against your foes but we warned
it only lasts a short time use tab to
activate when your gen pipe is charged
up
all right
Don't Mind If I Do all right so there's
got to be a puzzle here right
I could try to brute force it
but I won't ah here we go
ah the code 523 tell no one
good thing they made these so buzzly
oh boom
where'd that board go
I swear I just saw a board over here I
was reading one oh
[Music]
[Applause]
designation
required okay
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up
[Applause]
hey I do YouTube videos
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know if
I said not trouble
let's just talk
who are you
[Applause]
where did you come from
who made you
can you take me to him he wanted me to
find him
[Applause]
please let me see him
oh no
oh no
oh no
oh no
I'll never get out of here okay
well I've been deemed dangerous I'm sure
you could glean that from everything
that I said
foreign
extreme reaction
ah I don't know what that is
but oh well I'll whack it with a pipe
it is what I do
I do enjoy Whomping things also what is
with all the dead bodies I I haven't
commented on that yet but there are
quite a few dead bodies there's a lot of
death
get ready for a whopping oh
you kill immediately
how about this
goddam yo yo yo yo yo okay all right so
there ain't no coming back from womp and
that
um good uh I won't try that anymore
where'd you go oh you're over there
stupid
you can't stop my flow
ah
oh hello
what is that
the success
[Music]
upon a reception
Wilson will expect
the look of the creatures
okay well I'm sure that all went very
well and you did your job exceptionally
well just like everybody in this place
seems to be doing all the time everybody
just doing their job breaking Cycles or
not or whatever I don't know what you
want
oh
oh
something like that
oh
this is Card Exchange I guess I could do
this
now that I don't need to buy an upgrade
ever again and I definitely won't need
any of this stuff like uh those tool
kits yeah
hahaha
nice
nice where does this go
anywhere good
anywhere where I should be
anybody
anybody or anything
oh this is cycle Smackover well that's
unfortunate timing oh you didn't see
anything
you didn't see anything okay
enough time continue for now so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
thank you for enjoying this adventure
with me it will continue and we'll get
to the bottom of Bendy
and the dark Revival of ink machines in
the next episode
bye-bye
[Music]